my name is James Morton and I'm the head
of nutrition for Team Sky when it comes
to nutritional strategies for the
classics in many ways it's harder than a
grand tour of stairs actually because of
course you've got the intensity of the
stage you've also got the duration of
the stage and actually the writers can't
really come back to the car to get any
extra products and then last but not
least is we've got the environmental
temperatures so sometimes it can be very
very cold and wet during a classic stage
so when it comes to fuel and really it's
textbook nutrition carbohydrate is king
and we really are trying to hit those
high targets 75 to 90 grams per hour a
lot of writers don't do that in training
so we have to practice that in training
and if we do our job right we come to
the classic stages and the writers are
well prepared on how to take on board
that amount of carbohydrate and
hopefully we've done all of the planning
hopefully all of the writers are
educated on how to take on this extra
fuel and hopefully we win the races and
then when the race proceeds we then try
to switch to more semi solos and that's
where the gels comes in and of course
we're consistently fueling with the
fluids so if you like if you take one of
those pieces of carbohydrate roughly
there between 20 to 25 grams and that's
a unit of carbohydrate and we try and
educate our riders to get three or four
units per hour but we definitely make
the transition from solids to fluids to
semi solos towards the end of the race
and of course when the riders really
need a pick up towards the end of the
risk then that's where the caffeine gels
come in quite handy so recovery again is
probably one of the most important
aspects of nutrition for cycling in our
view and recovery for the classics might
be considered different from recovery
from a ground sewer but actually in the
classic season the race has come thick
and fast so although you might not be
racing the next day you might be racing
the day after that so what we have to
try and do is manage the recovery in TXO
the riders weight stay pretty stable so
in other words they don't eat too much
but actually they don't eat too little
and that's really my job to try and get
to know the rider other body handles
food to know the energy expenditure of
the duration of that stage to work with
the coaches on the recovery loads and
the tree and loads the next day to try
and manage weird throughout that classic
season
you